Музыка Herzlich willkommen, das ist an der Gitarre, mal wieder Florentin Will, meine Ladies and Gentlemen, der sich zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO begrüsst. Ja, vielen Dank, hallo, willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO. Stefan raus, was will er denn? Warum ist Stefan dabei? Ich freue mich schon seit einer Woche auf das Podcast UFO und jetzt ist Stefan dabei. Was soll das denn? Lol, ihr habt das Format überhaupt nicht verstanden. Nein, ich bin Team Stefan und der ist viel cooler als Florentin. Kann der nicht mal gehen? Nein, Florentin ist viel cooler. Hashtag Team Florentin. Ich mag den nicht mit seinem beschissenen Kackhumor da immer, mit dem Klamaukige, was er hier reinbringt.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Dieses Depressive, ich bin ein bisschen depressiv.
Was soll denn der Scheiss?
Ja, so klingt ihr.
Das seid ihr.
Da haben wir euch mal den Spiegel vorgehalten.
Fickt euch!
Da haben wir mal den Spiegel vorgehalten.
Das ist immer noch unser Podcast.
Das ist genau im Namen, ihr müsstet da nicht anhören.
Fickt ihr euch mal.
Das machen wir ja nur für uns hier.
Das machen wir ja gar nicht für euch oder für irgendwen anders da draußen. Das ist unser Ding, ihr müsst es ja nicht hören, wenn ihr nicht wollt. Haut ab! Scheiße. Ich habe massiven Scheiss gebaut, Florentin, und ich entschuldige mich. Alles klar, das ist okay. Ich bin bereit, dir zu verzeihen, alles ist in Ordnung. Es gibt, glaube ich, nichts, das so schlimm wäre, dass ich wirklich sauer auf dich wäre. Ich bin ein sehr, sehr ruhiger Mensch, der eigentlich sehr selten wirklich mal emotional wird und gerade bei solchen Kleinigkeiten, von denen ich jetzt mal ausgehe, dass du mir präsentieren wirst. Ich gucke mal auf unsere Webseite, ob sie noch online ist. Und jep, noch online, wunderbar. Die Webseite ist nicht down. Von daher, was kann gross passiert sein? Also, wir waren ja Montag bei den Rocket Beans, oder? Ja. So, da haben wir dann, der Trip war ja relativ... Du hast nicht deine scheiss Datei gelöscht. Der Trip war ja relativ erfolgreich, oder? Also vor allem, weil wir folgende Sachen gemacht haben. Du hast nicht deine scheiss Datei gelöscht, oder? Und dann konnten wir auch mit einem von den Rocket Beans einen Podcast aufnehmen. Wir wollten es eigentlich mit sehr vielen machen, haben es aber nur mit einem geschafft,
nämlich mit Nils Boronhoff. Und jetzt ist mir Folgendes passiert. Meine Festplatte war voll und ich habe alte Podcast-Ufo-Folgen gelöscht, alte Garage-Band-Projekte gelöscht. Und leider war da auch meine Nils-Boronhoff-Datei dabei. Ich kann sie nicht mehr finden und mein Papierkorb ist leer. Shit. Aber das, was du gerade fühlst, das ist Hass. Und da sind wir auch schon beim Thema unserer Folge, Hass. Und es ist gar nicht so schlecht, dass das, was du jetzt gerade fühlst, quasi exemplarisch für das Gefühl, was wir gerade beschreiben wollen, steht.
Ja, also ich habe mich schon noch auf die Folge gefreut und ich habe auch schon mir gedacht, okay, klar, die letzte Hotelfolge war vielleicht nicht so super, da kam das Feedback nicht so wahnsinnig gut rüber, aber wir haben ja noch die Nils-Bohmhoff-Folge, Nils-Bohmhoff ist Garant, ja, dem muss man einfach nur ein Mikrofon vor die Nase halten und da kommt ein Knaller-Gag nach dem anderen. Warst du jemals saurer auf mich? Ja, auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall. Shit, und es ist mir gerade eben erst aufgefallen. Wir müssen heute aber gut drauf sein. Dir ist schon klar, dass wenn die Folge jetzt auch nicht gut wird, haben wir ein riesiges Problem. Mit wem eigentlich nochmal genau? Also das verstehe ich immer nicht genau. Wem sind wir eigentlich was schuldig? Mit Stefan Schwier, unserem Top-Kommentator. Wem sind wir eigentlich was schuldig in unserem Freeware-Unterhaltungsding, was wir eine Stunde pro Woche raushauen, was wir nicht machen müssen, weil wir normale Jobs haben, was wir aus Spaß machen. Wem sind wir eigentlich was schuldig, warum müssen wir jede Woche drauf sein? Und wenn wir einmal nicht gut drauf sind, oder mal ein bisschen, was ja auch nicht stimmt, waren einfach sehr aufgedreht und haben eine experimentelle Folge gemacht. Warum kriegt man dann eigentlich so eine Welle aus Hass? Ja, es ist interessant. Es ist ja so ein bisschen das Thema der heutigen Folge, nicht wahr? Und wir waren mal bei den Rocket Beans unterwegs und ... Erinner mich nicht daran. Jetzt auch noch. Das erste Mal, als ich bei den Rocket Beans war, war es echt ein absoluter Lichtblick. Ich war zu Gast bei Bonjour, bei Almost Daily, ja, super gut, die Community hat super Feedback gegeben, waren total begeistert, die Jungs waren nett, alles war super geil. Und beim zweiten Mal dachte ich, es läuft halt genauso. Oh nein, oh nein, ich war tatsächlich zu Gast bei Pokémon und habe mir die Tiere in Pokémon gespielt. Ganz kurz mal eben, ihr wisst, dass wir in diesem Moment über das Thema Hass reden. So, ich hätte persönlich nie gedacht, dass wenn man über das Thema Hass redet, einen Satz anfangen kann mit, ich war bei der Episode Pokémon zu Gast. Pokémon! Das ist nur dafür da, um dich zu bespaßen. Warum kann ein Satz schon, um das Thema Hass zu beschreiben, damit anfangen mit, ich war bei Pokémon zu Gast. Ja, vor allem ist es interessant, weil man hat ja dieses klassische Publikum nicht mehr, das vor einem sitzt und einem direktes Feedback gibt, man hat aber trotzdem noch Zuschauer. Und es ist sehr interessant, weil du sitzt da wirklich spätabends um 22 Uhr in einem komplett leeren Raum, Vorne im Fernseher, als würdest du alleine zocken. Das einzige, was das von deinem Wohnzimmer unterscheidet, sind vier Kameras, die auf dich gerichtet sind. Aber ansonsten ist es komplett leise, man unterhält sich normal, aber trotzdem schauen einem irgendwie 20.000 Leute zu. Und das einzige Feedback, das man hat, hat man durch diesen Chat, und meine Aufgabe war es, irgendwann diesen Chat ein bisschen einzubeziehen in die Sendung. Allerdings war es nicht so schlecht, dass der Chat ständig eingefroren ist. Das heißt, ich hatte immer nur diesen unglaublichen Strom an Kommentaren, der in der enormen Geschwindigkeit reingekommen ist und dann ist alles eingefroren und dann konnte ich mir in Ruhe jeden einzelnen Kommentar durchlesen. Leider, leider. Ausschliesslich Hate. Florentin, raus, was will der eigentlich, der hat ja keine Ahnung. Ich habe mich die ganze Woche auf das Format gefreut und eher ruiniert das Format.
Ja, hier auch noch mal, möchte ich auch noch mal einhaken.
Vielleicht liegt es an dir, wenn es dich runterzieht, dass du dich die ganze Woche auf Pokémon freust und es dann ein junger Mann, der versucht, das Format mit seinen Gags noch nach vorne zu betreiben.
Wenn der das dann für dich kaputt machen kann, liegt das womöglich an dir. Vor allem ist das so ein interessantes Gefühl, weil du hast das Gefühl, dass draußen vor den Toren der Stadt gerade der Mob einfach aufläuft und die Fackeln angezündet werden und die Erde bebt und alle schreien, aber du kriegst davon nichts mit, du sitzt in einem klimatisierten Raum und denkst dir nur so, ach du Scheiße, und du hast ja kein Feedback.
Und draußen geht die Apokalypse los, keine Bäume mehr, einfach nur so eine Welle aus Feuer ist über die Welt gesteht. Und du denkst dir nur, wenn wir danach aus der Tür treten, es steht einfach alles in Flammen, meine Karriere ist vorbei, mein Twitter-Account wurde gehackt, mein Tinder-Profil wurde gelöscht, ich habe nichts mehr, woran ich meine Hoffnungen noch unterstützen kann. Alles ist weg, aber du musst noch eine Stunde diese Sendung machen und du hast auch kein neues Feedback. Du hast immer nur, Florettin, raus, was macht der Typ da? Ich habe mich die ganze Woche gefragt, du liest diese drei Kommentare immer und immer wieder, weil du immer denkst, okay, es kommen neue, das Internet ist wieder da. Es war so eine absurde Situation einfach, weil du hast gemerkt, ganz viele Leute sind gegen dich, aber die sind ganz weit weg und das ist ein komisches Gefühl eigentlich. Ja, und so eine ähnliche Situation haben
wir dann ja auch einen Tag später
erlebt bei Moin Moin. Wir durften
nämlich in Hamburg dann die Morning Show
auf der Rocket Beans moderieren, Moin Moin heisst sie
und da fing es ja schon
so an, ein bisschen problematisch für uns,
da
der Etienne, der
ein festes Ensemble-Mitglied die Sendung anmoderieren musste, weil ein Team von Arte da war. Und das führte dann dazu, dass alle dachten, yay, Eddie moderiert, moin moin, geil, bleib ich dran. Und wie cool, das wird bestimmt lustig, weil den kenne ich ja, ich habe mich gewöhnt an sein Gesicht. Und dann kommen irgendwann wir beide Nasen rein und sagen plötzlich, behaupten, wir übernehmen das jetzt. Und dieser Auftritt, der macht natürlich noch viel schlimmer, als wenn man direkt unsere beiden Fressen sieht und das einfach akzeptieren muss. Aber so hat man dann diese Übergabe nochmal visualisiert, was natürlich gar nicht gut ist. Das ist mal wieder Kontext. Ja, und vor allem die konkrete Situation war auch furchtbar, weil der neue Star Wars Trailer rauskam, auf den man sich seit vier Jahren einfach fucking gefreut hat. Und alle waren da, die ganzen Filmexperten waren da, Schröckert waren da, Andy Bardet war da, Etienne Gadi, also die drei Ikonen der cinematografischen Schaffenskraft der Rocket Beans waren da, haben sich diesen Trailer angeschaut und dann natürlich alle, ja was ist eure Meinung jetzt, okay, geil, jetzt diskutieren die diesen Trailer kaputt und geil und was sind die Hoffnungen und Insiderinfos, die kennen sich wahnsinnig gut aus.
Nee, die gehen und stattdessen kommen die beiden Volldeppen vom Studentensender rein und sagen, hallo, ja, wir haben keine Ahnung von Star Wars und wir machen jetzt weiter. Also die maximale Enttäuschung einfach nach diesem maximallangen Aufbau, endlich hat man das, was man haben will und dann, zack, kommen wir. Und auch da war die Situation wieder. Auch da war das Konzept ja einfach, dass man sich mit einem Laptop an einem Tisch setzt, davor hat man zwei Kameras, und mein Problem war noch, dazu kam noch, dass ich halt nicht wusste, in welche Kamera ich gucken sollte, und mein Bild, also stell dir mal kurz vor, ihr sitzt in einem Raum, man sieht den Hintergrund nicht, davor stehen zwei Kameras, du hast keine Ahnung, welche du gucken sollst, und drunter ist halt einfach nur ein Bildschirm. Der Rest deines Blickfeldes wird von einem Bildschirm gefüllt, wo jetzt aber keine Gänseblümchen oder lustige Schmetterlinge oder Katzenvideos zu sehen sind, sondern einfach Hass, Hass, einfach so ein Riesenschwall, so du bist in der Matrix, weil tausend Kommentare kommen und in so einem Chat und alle schreien nur, Was ist das? Auch nur in Caps, so man sieht, wenn die Meute vom draussen in der realen Welt langzieht mit Facken und Heugabeln, wer ist das, so ganz viele Smilies, die du nicht zuordnen kannst, weil das viel zu schnell geht, weil es viel zu viel Hass der Rüchung kommt. Die die auch gar nicht laden, weil die Bandbreite einfach zu überfordert ist. Das sind irgendwelche Fragezeichen, irgendwelche komischen kryptischen Symbolen, wo du nicht weisst, ist das ein Hakenkreuz oder ein Herz, einfach schlicht.
Aber auch wieder da die Situation. Wir sind in einem komplett leeren Raum alleine. Da steht nicht irgendwie ein Aufnahmeleiter, der irgendwie so Anweisungen gibt oder so. Und wir dachten uns, ja gut, wir stellen uns halt vor, reden fünf Minuten und gehen mal ein bisschen auf den Chat ein. Okay, Stefan, wir schauen mal kurz in den Chat. Du schaust in den Chat und dir ein epischer Stinkefinger-Ideen gegen Fickt euch! Ja, okay, Stefan, wie hat dir der Trailer gefallen? Na gut, reden wir weiter über Star Wars, reden wir weiter über belanglose Dinge, über die wir uns nicht mehr ganz konzentrieren können, weil wir gerade angegangen werden hart. Es ist wirklich furchtbar, weil die Unterhaltungsbranche schwankt ja zwischen unglaublich bester Job der Welt und wirklich schlimmste Situation der Welt, weil es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als einen Performer, den niemand sehen will. Einfach wenn du auf, keine Ahnung, du gehst zu einer Comedy-Veranstaltung und da kommt ein Zauberer und du willst einfach, niemand will einen Zauberer sehen oder irgendjemand fängt an zu Beatboxen und niemand will das und du machst es aber trotzdem. Etwas, das in einem anderen Kontext mega gut ankommen würde, ist plötzlich in diesem Kontext einfach grottenschlecht und das ist so schlecht, weil du machst ja genau das gleiche und der Kontext, du hast ja keinen Einfluss auf den Kontext. Das ist so ein bisschen schwierig. Und dann ist es plötzlich so, als ob eine Beerdigung von einem Comedian moderiert wird, der die ganze Zeit irgendwie Gags raushauen will, aber halt alle nicht zu feiern zumute ist. Und das ist dann echt so ein bisschen problematisch, vor allem beim Format, was auch Feedback aufbaut. Und wenn dann das Feedback reinkommt, dass sie das Format nicht verstanden haben, die da offensichtlich gerade beschimpft werden, frage ich mich auch, was sollen die denn machen? Was sollen die denn machen? Sollen die sagen, ja, danke für das konstruktive Feedback, danke Fickmaus93 für diese innovative Beleidigung? Ich kann mich noch erinnern, ich kann mich noch erinnern, die erste Folge von Joyce, wobei Joyce immer so, wir sind ja mega interaktive Sender, ihr macht das Programm, ihr könnt das Programm gestalten, die hatten immer einen Monitor im Hintergrund, wo die Kommentare eingeblendet wurden waren und in den ersten Sendungen einfach nur Hitler, Hitler, Penis, Hass, Hass, Hass, Holocaust, Holocaust, sechs Millionen Juden tot, Hass, Hass, Penis, Penis, Penis. Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an die Situation, wenn Menschen zu viel Freiraum haben, wie in diesem Galileo-Beitrag, den ich noch nicht mal gesehen habe, dann schmeissen sie einfach so ein Feuerwerk ins Feuer, aber einfach das ganze Paket. Das ist so ein bisschen sinnbildlich, wenn Menschen zu viele Freiheiten haben, machen sie unfassbare Dummheiten. Die denken ich erst nach. Wenn so ein Radio-, so ein Fernsehreporter irgendwo steht, irgendwie ein brenntes Haus, die Feuerwehrmänner tragen noch irgendwie verkohlte Kinderleichen raus, aber es gibt natürlich immer die fünf Dorfvoll Deppen, die es nicht nehmen lassen, hinter der Reporterin sich irgendwie nackt auszuziehen und so tun, als würden sie sich gegenseitig gerade sexuell befriedigen und denkst einfach nur, Alter, wo kommt ihr her, was ist das für eine Welt, wo innerhalb von 30 Sekunden eine Kamera steht und es kommen es kommen einfach irgendwelche Trolle und einfach Trollen und einfach, das ist einfach so dieser urmenschliche Instinkt, alles Schöne irgendwie zu zerstören.
Ich verstehe nicht, wo das hier ist.
Aber ich liebe diesen Instinkt, ich finde das grossartig.
Ich finde es auch toll, aber nicht, wenn ich daran beteiligt bin, unmittelbar.
Es darf nicht dich selbst helfen.
Nee, vor allem, ich frage mich auch immer, es gibt drei Stufen von Hass meiner Meinung nach. Die erste Stufe von Hass ist die in dich hinein hassen. Ich hasse die Person, die vor mir an der Kasse mit Kleingeld bezahlen will. Aber ich hasse sehr viel in dieser Stufe eins. Ich denke, du auch, also das macht, glaube ich, jeder. Absolut. Manchmal, aber Hass ist ja was Wunderschönes, weil Hass ist ja etwas, das sich sehr schwer überträgt. Und man kann ja, wenn man selber hasst, ist ja was ganz anderes, als wenn jemand anders hasst. Zum Beispiel war ich gerade im ICE unterwegs und da ist immer die Situation, wenn der ICE ankommt und alle stehen auf und dann wollen immer alle wahnsinnig schnell raus und drängeln sich vor, obwohl es irgendwie eine Zeitersparnis von zwei Sekunden ist. Und auch, weißt du, die Hälfte des ICEs war vor allem Leute, die an der Schlange stehen, da war eine kleine Lücke und dann war eine Familie, die gerade ihr Gepäck zusammengepackt hat, danach stand ich und danach noch ein Typ. Und der Typ war mega angepisst, dass ich jetzt gerade darauf warte, dass diese Familie ihre Taschen runterholt, obwohl es eh keinen Sinn gegeben hätte, weil man, wenn man weitergegangen wäre, ja sowieso an das Ende der nächsten Schlange gekommen ist. Und ich stand nur so da und habe hinter mir gespürt, wie dieser Mann bebt und pocht und so ganz nervös. Wobei das schon fast Stufe zwei. Das waren so wie Flügel des Hasses, die hinter mir so aufgeschwungen sind. Und ich habe mich gefühlt wie ein Engel der Rache, der da steht und einfach sagt, nein, ich genieße das jetzt einfach mal, wie dieser Typ hinter mir einfach innerlich brodelt und seine Haut langsam abfällt und wirklich nur die Lava unter ihm hervorquält.
Und es war so, für mich war es das Schönste der Welt einfach in dem Moment, es war herrlich. Das habe ich ja auch immer, wenn ich in der U-Bahn-Sitzung neben mir meinen Rucksack gestellt habe und es kommen Leute zu mir und fragen mich, ob die da sitzen könnten.
Und dann denke ich mir auch immer, der erste Moment ist immer, ja klar, ich meine, der Rucksack ist da jetzt irgendwie nicht festgeklebt oder so, ich kann den einfach nehmen und wegstellen, ist ja jetzt kein Problem, warum fragen die mich, ob sie da sitzen können, aber ich hasse sie trotzdem, ich hasse sie, warum müssen sie sich da hinsetzen, es sind andere Plätze in der U-Bahn frei, warum wählen sie den Platz neben mir?
Das ist halt so, dieses in sich hinein, hassen, auch manchmal ohne Grund, das ist auch oft nicht rational.
Aber dann kommt Stufe zwei für mich schon.
Hassen, um etwas ändern zu wollen, zu seinen Gunsten, weil der Typ hinter dir zum Beispiel, wäre für mich schon Hass Stufe zwei gewesen,
weil er hat schon diese Geräusche gemacht, weil er die Situation ändern will.
Er will schon irgendwie, dass du weggehst, dass die Familie weggeht, stirbt oder was auch immer, damit er weitergehen kann. Und das ist schon dieses offensive Hassen. Auch meine Nachbarn gehen mir sehr oft auf die Nerven, aber noch bin ich bei Stufe 1, irgendwann bin ich bei Stufe 2. Du stehst dann den ganzen Tag in deinem Wohnzimmer und... Ja, genau, aber zu Stufe 2 gehe ich über, wenn ich wütend mit einem Besen an die Wand klopfe, dann gehe ich zu Stufe zwei über, weil ich was ändern will. So, und dann gibt es diese Leute in Chats oder in Kommentarspalten bei WordPress, ohne spezifisch sein zu wollen, die dann Stufe drei anwenden, nämlich anonym nach außen den Hassen, ohne was ändern zu wollen. Es ist die schlimmste Art des Hassens. Die wollen nicht, dass die Situation sich gerade ändert. Die wollen einfach nur hassen. Vielleicht ist es manchmal auch einfach als Scherz gemeint. Genau, kurz als Regel, Ironie funktioniert nicht bei Twitch. Ironie funktioniert auch nicht bei WordPress oder bei Facebook, bei Twitter vielleicht ein bisschen, aber eigentlich auch nicht. Und wenn er eineie benutzt, die nicht ankommt und ihr sagt, oh, ihr hattet einfach nur meine Ironie nicht verstanden, nein, wir beschäftigen uns professionell mit Comedy, wir arbeiten, wir verdienen damit unser Geld. Oh, wir sind wieder so sympathisch, dass das tut, absolut nicht gehatet zu werden, dass das, was ihr macht, ist falsch, wir verstehen es besser als ihr. Nein, das war nur ein Scherz, den ich machen konnte, weil ich professionell mit Comedy arbeite. Aber es ist echt interessant, vor allem, es gibt ja verschiedene, wie gesagt, verschiedene Formen des Hasses. Im Twitch-Dad hatten wir so ein bisschen diesen Shotgun-Hass, dieses schnell einfach rausgefeuert und mehr oder weniger gleich wieder vergessen. Aber dann gibt es ja noch andere Formen, dann zum Beispiel bei YouTube-Kommentaren oder auf Reddit gab es ja dann wirklich seitenlange Erklärungen, in denen präzise erörtert wurde, warum ich scheiße war bei Pokémon und warum wir scheiße waren. Moin, moin, moin. Und das ist ja das Interessante, dass es ja einerseits diesen instinktiven, subjektiven Ich hasse dich Hass gibt, aber dann noch so diesen Ich erkläre jetzt mal mein Weltbild dahinter und die Ideologie, die dazu führt, warum ich dich hasse und warum du das nicht verstanden hast. Und dann einfach da aber auch Ironie komplett ausgeschaltet. Also ich habe bei diesem Pokémon-Format grösslich einfach nur Scheiße erzählt und die Leute dann so, äh, das stimmt aber nicht, was du erzählt hast, das stimmt nicht, dass Misty mit Nachnamen Longbottom heißt. Und wir denken so, das ist doch offensichtlich ein Gag wegen Neville Longbottom, so das ist doch, in welcher Situation würde ich das denn als tatsächliches Wissen unterbringen wollen, dachten die, ich hätte das verwechselt mit Harry Potter und würde ich denken, Misty heisst, oder was ist das, wovon geht das aus? Wir haben eigentlich mal in so einer haptischen Situation sehr viel Hass entgegenbekommen. Hast du das mal erlebt? Also jetzt nicht so über den Chat oder irgendwie über drei Ecken, sondern einfach nur Hass, also während du da warst im Raum, Hass gegen dich erlebt. Weiß ich gar nicht. Ich hätte das einmal erlebt und da waren wir noch sehr jung als Band und haben bei einem Bandwettbewerb mitgemacht, wo wir nicht wussten, dass der eigentlich gedacht ist, eher für ältere Bands, also wir waren irgendwie 13, 14 so Bubis halt, die niemand interessiert haben. Bubis. Bubis. Und da waren halt sehr viele erwachsene Bands und auch Jugendliche dabei, die es sehr ernst genommen haben. Und es war halt so eine Art Metal-Wettbewerb. Also es war, glaube ich, nicht ausgeschrieben so, aber es war halt einer. Es haben nur so Death-Metal-Bands, die die ganze Zeit geschautet haben und crazy Sachen gesagt haben und halt ihre riesen Communities mitgenommen haben zu diesem Auftritt. Und dann waren wir da halt, die irgendwie drei Akkorde konnten und mit einer Ukulele auf der Bühne standen. Und das war zum ersten Mal, wo ich wirklich sehr viel Hass entgegenbekommen habe. Also es war einfach, wir konnten einfach die Musik nicht mehr hören, weil vor lauter Buf, Rufen und Pfiffen und so, also da war sehr viel Hass dabei. Und da kannst du halt auch nicht mit umgehen. Also noch unsouveräner, als wenn es nur über den Chat läuft. Das ist schon sehr furchtbar. Ich hatte mal eine Situation im Schulferien, Schullandheim, Schullandheim, Skilager waren wir und da gab es dann am Ende so einen bunten Abend, wo die Lehrer was vorbereitet haben und dann kam so dieser Satz.
Du hattest mich beim Bund.
Auf jeden Fall.
Da kam dann so dieser Satz, ja, und wer von euch noch irgendwas Lustiges vorbereiten will, irgendwie ein Spiel oder was vorführen möchte, der kann das auch machen.
Durch irgendeine Raumzeitsperre, durch irgendeinen Filter, der sich aufgetan hat, kam das bei meinem besten Freund und mir so an, als ihr müsst was machen. Was dazu geführt hat, dass an dem tatsächlichen Abend die Lehrer ihr Ding gemacht haben und dann, ja, wer hat denn von euch noch was vorbereitet, wir die einzigen waren. Auf jeden Fall haben wir dann unser Ding gemacht und wir hatten die tolle Idee, Pantomime zu machen, dass wir irgendwie irgendwas pantomimisch gemacht haben und mussten die anderen Leute erraten, was es war und der, der es erraten hat, musste dann reinkommen und die nächste Nummer machen, was ein ganz schlechtes System ist, weil wenn keiner Bock hat, Pantomime zu machen, rät auch niemand, was du machst und du stehst einfach sieben Minuten lang dir gegenüber und spielst einfach Tennis, sehr offensichtlich und die Schüler immer, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein könnte. Aber können Sie bitte aufhören damit? Ich muss mal ein bisschen mehr angucken. So offensichtlich wollte jeder was anderes machen gerade, war froh, dass der Abend vorbei ist. Ja, alle wollten, scheiße, ich will einfach nur mit Rebecca rumknutschen, bitte lass mich hier raus. Und wir, Aufschlag und einfach die Lehrer sagen, habt ihr einen Schaden? Ich habe nach vier Sekunden verstanden, dass es Tennis ist, aber alle Schüler so, nee, wir lassen euch da jetzt einfach zappeln. Und das war so eine Situation, weil niemand wollte die Situation auflösen, aber alle haben darunter gelitten, dass niemand die Situation auflöst. Also es war so eine Selbstgeisselung konstant und alle haben uns so gehasst. Aber das prägt dich. Das Ereignis hat dich nachhaltig geprägt, glaube ich. Das war auch die unglaubliche Situation, eine lustigste Situation, die ich je erlebt habe, als ich mit meinem Freund in München unterwegs war. Und wir sind leider, obwohl wir versucht haben, drumherum zu manövrieren und irgendwie Ausweichschritte und Ausfallschritte und uns versucht haben zu verstecken, sind wir in einen Junggesell in den Abschied geraten. Ganz, ganz bitter. Das ist dann wirklich so, ich mag dann immer auch noch die, man läuft so darauf zu und man unterhält sich vielleicht, man hat die Umgebung nicht so ganz vor Augen und man sieht so aus dem Augenwinkel, oh shit und es ist noch so 20 Meter weg und man versucht noch so wegzulaufen, aber sie haben die schon im Blick.
Und mit den Angelsflügelchen sind sie auch einfach schneller, mit den Feenflügeln, die sie sich anziehen mussten, sind sie auch einfach schneller weiter als sie.
Und die Metallkugel, die sie sich umbein gekettet haben und die kleinen Schnäpse, die sie verkaufen, werfen sie auch nicht und dann haben sie nicht.
Und da war die unglaubliche Situation, wo mein Freund und ich haben jeweils einen Schokokuss bekommen. Und es hieß, okay, wer diesen Schokokuss als erstes aufgegessen hat, darf die zukünftige Braut küssen. Und wir schauen beide diese Braut an, schauen uns an, okay, das wird ein langer Abend. Und wir haben beide, okay, drei, zwei, eins. Und wir haben beide wirklich so winzige Bissen abgebissen und versuchen diesen Choco-Kurs so langsam, wie es geht, während dessen konstant Augenkontakt gehalten, so einfach Kopf schütteln, so nein. Und das ist so lustig, weil die anderen Junggesellenabschiedsfrauen einfach so, okay, schnell beeilig, go, go, go, schneller. Und die haben überhaupt nicht gerafft, was wir gemacht haben. Aber wir haben sich seit zwölf Minuten knabbeln jetzt an dem Ding rum, komm, schneller, du schaffst es, okay, schnell, beeil dich, go, go, go, schneller, und die haben überhaupt nicht gerafft, was wir gemacht haben, wir hatten sich seit zwölf Minuten knabbeln, die jetzt an dem Ding rum, komm, schneller, du schaffst es, ja, schnell, und wir einfach, oh Gott, und das war auch so schlecht, weil irgendwann ist halt jemand fertig, und das ist, was ich, meine Philosophielehrerin hat mir sehr viel mit auf den Weg gegeben, aber eins, was ich nie vergessen werde, sie hat immer gesagt, wenn man hasst und reagieren will darauf, dann soll man erst mal bis zehn zählen. Und das habe ich, das ist wirklich nichts. Können wir ganz kurz das Wort Philosophie nochmal in die grösstmöglichen Anführungszeichen der Welt setzen? Das war übrigens die, die aber auch irgendwie, ich habe irgendwie mit besonderer Leistung am Ende aus irgendeinem seltsamen Grund, weil sich das Universum vertan hat, der uncoolste Mensch der Welt den K Kurs abgeschlossen mit einer herausragenden Leistung. Und dann musste sie mir ein Geschenk machen, hat sie jedem, der das gemacht hat. Und dann hat sie mir ein Buch über Gewalt geschenkt. Was ich auch... Sie hat jedem gesagt, so der Lisa, die hat sich besonders für den Autolitarismus interessiert. Kriegst du ein Buch über den Autolitarismus? Ah, Pflichtethik, Kant, hat der Vivian immer so viel Spaß gemacht. Jam, jam, jam, lecker, lecker. Wir, gern für dich dieses Buch und ich pack aus, Hannah Arendt, Gewalt. So, why, warum, warum ich Gewalt, was habe ich denn damit zu tun? Und sie hat mir auch gesagt, sie hat mir diesen Tipp auf den Weg gegeben, der irgendwie auch ein bisschen random mir vorkam, dass ich mal bis zehn zählen soll, wenn ich hasse.
Du wirst wahrscheinlich nach außen wieder mega Choleriker, aber innerlich bist du einfach völlig friedlieb. Ja, und seitdem zähle ich mal bis zehn und danach ist man echt ein bisschen, man hat Zeit, um auf sich selber herabzuschauen in der Vogelperspektive, das hilft echt. Aber was ganz anderes nochmal kurz, zum Thema Hass. Wir waren dann von beiden Rocket Beans und konnten dann Dienstag, sind wir dann im Zug nach Hause gefahren, nach Köln, und dann durften wir abends zum Comedypreis. Eine illustre Veranstaltung, wir haben es mal wieder geschafft, uns irgendwie da reinzuschmuggeln, und da möchte ich gerne auf die Evolution des Florentin Will auf dem Comedypreis eingehen, die am Ende des Abends auch nur noch aus Hass bestand, weil er, man muss es sagen, Lena Mayer-Landrut nicht gefunden hat.
Lena Mayer-Landrut war anwesend und hat gesungen für Stefan Raabs grossen Abschiedsmoment. War da, Florentin hat sie nicht gefunden und es war eine lustige Veranstaltung, Florentin hat zunächst getanzt, er war erleichtert, er war froh, er hat sich gefreut über den Abend und ihn mit seinen Freunden zu verbringen und mit der lieben Lena Meilandruth zum Beispiel vielleicht. Mal gucken, was der Abend noch bringt, er hat gelacht, herzhaft gelacht, da hat er schon die Krawatte ein bisschen lockerer gemacht und hat einen getrunken und war froh und hat tanzt hier mittendrauf und hat den Moonwalk gemacht. Und so minute zu minute als es immer wahrscheinlicher war dass lehrmann schon nicht mehr im gebäude befindlich ist ist die mine halt immer ein bisschen saurer geworden und am ende war es einfach nur noch hass am ende war es nur noch hass und er ist mit so einer ganz fiesen fiesen so ganz fiesen blick über den comedypreis gelaufen der lustigsten veranstaltung des jahren alle anderen haben gelacht lagen eigentlich konstant lachend am Boden und haben sich umhergewählt. Und du bist so rumgestampft mit so einem ganz fiesen Blick. Das war nicht sehr lustig. Das war schrecklich. Ja, vor allem, ich habe die ganze Zeit irgendwelche anderen Leute gefragt und es ist ja tatsächlich so eine krasse Hierarchie, wenn du irgendwie Leute, die du normalerweise bewundern würdest, sind, wenn noch berühmtere Leute als sie im Raum sind, plötzlich nichts mehr wert, sind einfach Dreck. Jemanden, denen, keine Ahnung, wie so ein, ähm, ja, was weiß ich halt, egal, wir müssen jetzt auch kein Name-Dropping betreiben, also ein Typ, wo man normalerweise sagen würde, okay, krass, okay, geil, der Typ, oh, der kommt ins Podcast-Ufo, geil, sobald er da steht, einfach neben Bastian Pastewka, denkst du dir, okay, fick dich, kannst du ganz kurz zur Seite gehen, ich will kurz awkward neben Bastian Pastewka stehen, damit jemand ein Foto machen kann, in dem es vielleicht zufällig so aussieht, als würden wir uns unterhalten, okay, danke, ciao. So, das ist dann echt so krass und ich habe dann alle möglichen Leute angesprochen, ob sie Liedermeyer-Landhut gesehen haben und am Anfang ging es noch so ein bisschen von Zurückhaltung bis ehrlicher Hilfe wie, ah ja, ich glaube, die habe ich da hinten gesehen, zu, ich glaube, ich wurde am Ende einfach verarscht von Leuten, Weil auch wenn irgendwie sich herumgesprochen hat, dass Leder mal Landruth bereits verlassen, die ihr eigenes verlassen hatte, haben die Leute mir einfach irgendwelche Tipps gegeben, ja, ja, da oben auf der Treppe hier, da muss rumgehen und ich bin einfach wild durch die Gegend gehechtet hier hinterher und sie glaube ich war schon einfach ewig lang in ihrem Hotelzimmer und hat von mir geträumt hoffentlich. Aber auch da mal ganz kurz, weisst du, ich gebe mir echt Mühe, irgendwie cool auf Partys zu sein und so und man kommt dann dann da an und hat einen Anzug an und eigentlich ist alles okay und so. Und dann war halt auch der erste Teil, die ersten Minuten an der Party entscheiden ja schon so ein bisschen, wie man den Rest des Lebens ankommt. Genau, und es gab aber dann einmal die Leute mit VIP-Passen und die ohne. Und Kolleginnen von uns hatten keinen VIP-Pass, wir aber schon. Und in der VIP-Area gab es den ganzen Alkohol. Und deswegen haben sie mir gesagt, hey Florentin, hol uns doch mal einfach Alkohol. Und ich so, ja klar, Ladies, besorge ich euch überhaupt kein Problem, kein Stress, kenne ich mich gut mit aus. Hol diesen Alkohol, hab dann zwei volle Weissweingläser in der Hand und find halt einfach unsere Kollegin nicht mehr. Und dann renne ich halt einfach 20 Minuten über diesen scheiß ComedypreisComedy-Preis, gucke und suche, und ich glaube, suchen ist das Uncoolste, was man auf einer Party machen kann. Ja, aber man ist nur am Suchen, das nervt mich ja auch immer. Alle rennen immer nur rum und niemand ist auffindbar und überall diese Musik. Die ganze Zeit ist man nur einmal mehr rumgucken, das ist mir auch doll aufgefallen. Und ich hatte sehr oft awkward Blickkontakt mit Leuten wie Bastian Pastewka. Halsschmerz, Halsschmerz, Nackenschmerzen. Und ja, vor allem bei uns grossen Leuten ist es auch noch so, dass man sich ständig sieht. Ich habe ständig Olivia Jones halt. So ein Leer von Haaren unter euch. Ich musste ständig Olivia Jones angucken, weil sie immer auf Milliarden Meter hohen Schuhen, irgendwie drei Meter achtzig groß, auf dieser Veranstaltung herum tänzelt. Und andauernd sieht man halt, auf so einem Mär von kleinen Leuten sehen sich halt die über zwei Meter grossen Menschen immer andauernd. Und andauernd muss sich Olivia Jones angucken. Ganz unangenehm. Es gibt einfach zwei Arten von Menschen auf Partys, die die suchen und die die gesucht werden. Und dann gibt es einfach nur die dritte Kategorie, die mit irgendwie zwei Weissweinglässern in der Hand einfach wild durch die Gegend läuft und einfach guckt.
Es war einfach mega uncool und ich dachte mir schon, Alter, fuck, schon wieder nicht geschafft, cool auf einer Party zu sein. Das wurde dann auch nicht besser. Aber naja. Aber eigentlich wieder eine tolle Veranstaltung und wir haben ganz tolle Gäste. Ja, wir haben ein paar Gäste akkuriert, die wir jetzt alle noch nicht verraten können. Die wir alle noch nicht verraten können. Aber ich sag mal so, drei Meter achtzig war schon kein schlechter Hinweis, Knickknack, freut euch auf Folge dreiundfünfzig. So viel sei gesagt. Ganz kurz, wir haben ja vor einigen Wochen eine neue Rubrik eröffnet. Ja. Stefan Tesco, Ghost Extrovert. Stefan Titzel ist ein neuer Mensch. Alle sieben Jahre beginnt ein neuer Lebensabschnitt, Stefan ist 21 geworden.
Nein, alle drei Wochen beginnt ein neuer Lebensabschnitt.
Stimmt, du hast die Regel geändert, glaube ich. Deswegen, Stefan Titzel trägt jetzt coole Hemden mit lustigen Vögeln drauf und er hat sich, um seine exzentrische Natur weiter zu frönen, ein neues Fortbewegungsmittel gekauft. Und jetzt will ich einfach mal nach zwei Wochen mal so einen kleinen Rückblick machen, so wie hat das funktioniert, du hast ja einen Swag-. Nein, nein, nein, nein, so nennen das Leute, so nennen das Böse Zungen, nennen das Swagway, weil sie die Swagway-Fahrer in so einer uncoolen Gruppe machen sollen, das ist eine Lobbybildung, die mir gar nicht gefällt. Dass es selbst unter den Segway-Fahrern noch eine ungekohle Lobby gibt. Es geht einfach immer weiter nach unten, es ist egal, wie tief du bist. Unter dir ist immer noch der Swagway-Fahrer. Der Swagway-Fahrer ist relativ weit unten. Ich zähle mich nicht zum Swagway-Fahrer, weil, naja, also ich habe das Ding bekommen, es kam an, ich war sehr froh, in heller Freude und in heller Erwartungshaltung habe ich dieses Paket aufgemacht. Die verpixelte Verpackung hat mich nicht negativ gestimmt. Und dann habe ich das Gerät ausgepackt, es hat alles gut funktioniert, ich bin drauf rumgefahren, rumgefahren, und dann habe ich mich mehr getraut. Und dann ging es so weiter, dass ich irgendwann schon sehr souverän auf diesem Gerät fahren konnte, was wirklich herausragend ist, also ein ganz tolles Produkt, eine ganz tolle Erfindung und es ist wirklich auch total geil, damit rumzufahren. Aber irgendwann konnte ich halt schneller damit fahren und dann irgendwann ist halt ein Rad ausgegangen, während ich relativ schnell durch meine Wohnung gefahren bin, was dazu führte, dass ich sehr doll hingefallen bin. Also ich bin wirklich doll hingefallen. Und dann dachte ich mir, seitdem liegt es hier noch da, wo es hingefallen ist. Und ich gucke es an und ich habe so ein bisschen das Vertrauen verloren. Und ich warte jetzt so ein paar Monate, um langsam wieder das Vertrauen für dieses Gerät zurückzuarbeiten, weil ich finde, es ist schon so ein bisschen so eine Symbiose zwischen Gerät und Fahrer, weil du musst sehr schnell fahren im Straßenverkehr, wo die Leute beobachten, die eh schon die ganze Zeit sagen wollen, das ist uncool, was er da macht. Ich will denen aber zeigen, es ist wahnsinnig cool, was ich da mache, weil ich fahre einfach schneller als ihr und ich muss nicht mehr gehen, ich kann das Gehen einstellen. Und deswegen will ich den Leuten einfach keinen Grund geben, indem ich hinfalle, dass sie lachen oder sagen, gut, das ist echt scheiße, was er da hat. Deswegen versuche ich mich langsam, mit langsamen Schrittes zurück an dieses Gerät zu arbeiten und so ein bisschen das Vertrauen zurückzunehmen. Aber wieder ist es ein Risiko, ne? Es ist mal was Neues ausprobieren und...
Aber weißt du was? Ich finde, ich gebe ein bisschen Geld aus für sowas, um ein bisschen neue Sachen zu, ein bisschen Impulse zu streuen. Nicht nur bei mir selber im Leben, sondern auch bei dem Leben der ganzen Leute in meinem Blog, in meinem Wohnblog. Die sehen mich darauf rumfahren und die haben plötzlich was zu erzählen. Alte Menschen laufen rum und sagen, hey, hast du es gesehen, da ist jemand lang geschwebt, der musste nicht mehr gehen, der ist über die Bordsteine geschwebt wie ein junger Gott. Und die haben noch was zu erzählen, ihren Lebenspartnern bzw. Enkeln. Ich stelle es mir so lustig vor, du lebst ja im Erdgeschoss und erzählst, was du da für tolle Sachen siehst, aber gibt es was Cooleres, als in der Wohnung zu sitzen, aus dem Fenster zu schauen und da fährt jemand im Erdgeschoss an den Fensterfront vorbei und du siehst eigentlich, worauf er fährt? Nein, du siehst einfach nur, der schwebt. Der ist so wie der Stockgerade da, der ist so wie dieser klassische Gag hinter dem Sofa eine Treppe runterlaufen. Ja, wie so ein Dementor schwebt er da ran. Ja, finde ich großartig, finde ich super. Und das sind diese Impulse, du kannst nicht selber für dich was tun, sondern auch für alle Menschen um dich herum und Leute, die dich sehen. Finde ich ganz großartig. Wie gesagt, Vertrauen habe ich verloren, erst mal. Aber ich zähle bis zehn, sehr lange gerade, über mehrere Wochen zähle ich bis zehn, bis ich das Vertrauen wieder gewonnen habe. Hast du das mal gemacht, diesen Gag mit dem hinter der, also hinter einer Obscure, etwas Verbergendes, einem Sichtschutz?
Massive Wortfindungsstörungen. Ich lasse dich noch ein bisschen zappeln. Hinter einem, naja, wie könnte man sagen, eine Sperre ist ja schon wieder irgendwie anders auf einen anderen Kontext ausgelegt. Hinter einer Balustrade, hinter einem Sichtschutz. Aber auch nicht ganz, sondern nur ein Sichtschutz des unteren Zeils des Körpers. Ja, in einem teilweise bis zum Schritt dich bedeckenden Sichtfeldsperre. Hast du schon mal dahinter mal diesen generellen Partygag gemacht, sodass du so getan hast, als würdest du eine Treppe runtergehen? Ja. Okay, Paul und Carina schauen dir gerade zu. Du sagst, hey Leute, guckt mal, Leute, bitte, Leute, Leute, und Paul, Paul, könnt ihr kurz die Musik ausmachen, bitte? Könnt ihr bitte kurz aufhören, rumzuknutschen? Ja, Paul und Carina, die gerade rumknutschen, schauen beide gemeinsam gerade auf. Gelangweil, schauen sie mir. Okay, du hast ihre Aufmerksamkeit, jetzt go, was machst du jetzt? So, ich stelle mich hinter diesen Sichtschutzbarrierenzaun und mache den Gag. Zunächst die Treppe, ich gehe lang.
Paul ist genervt,
Carina lacht.
Carina ist ein bisschen angetan.
Aber sie macht es nur, damit ich aufhöre.
Du hast sie am Haken, würde ich mal sagen.
Dann hast du zwei Möglichkeiten.
Der Aufzug oder das Kanu?
Entweder du bleibst liegen unten,
um diesen Effekt,
den du gerade versucht hast darzustellen, noch ein bisschen, um die Illusionen so ein bisschen glaubhafter zu machen, dass du einfach nicht mehr auftauchst, weil du bist ja gerade die Treppe runtergegangen und da tauchst du wieder auf. Eigentlich muss man es durchziehen und gar nicht mehr auftauch für die ganze Party, einfach hinter dem Sofa liegen bleiben für den Gag. Ich muss gar nicht mehr auflaufen. Oh Mann, Entschuldigung. Hat aber auch was mit Sofa zu tun, weil es ja schwierig ist, du liegst dann dahinter Sofa und wie... Weißt du da irgendwie einen anderen Podcast, was ist los? Der wüsste ja jetzt. In der Zeitung, nee, weil Radio 1 liegt. Nee, hinter der Zeitung, ich habe mal in einem Theaterstück mitgespielt und da ging es darum, dass es so ein Hotel gibt zwischen Erde und Himmel und dass Leute, die so in Todesgefahr schweben, in diesem Hotel sind und dann halt so als Geister miteinander reden. Vollkommen egal. Auf jeden Fall, es gibt so einen Aufzug, der dann eben die Leute, wenn sie überleben, wieder auf die Erde zurückfährt oder wenn sie sterben in den Himmel fährt. Und die Idee war halt, dass es am Anfang die Bühne ist komplett schwarz und dann hört man halt so Brausen und kosmische Geräusche und was auch immer. Und dann geht dieser Aufzug auf und wieder zu und dann geht das Licht an und ich, weil ich die Hauptfigur gespielt habe, der gerade angekommen ist in diesem Hotel, stehe hinter dem Sofa auf und eine, wow, toll. Und ich konnte nicht tatsächlich aus dem Aufzug rauskommen, sondern ich lag schon die ganze Zeit, das ist der Gag, hinter dem Sofa. Das heisst, die gesamte Zeit, während das Publikum gerade reingekommen ist, irgendwie sich noch was zu trinken gekauft hat, also in Ordnung, lag ich zusammengekauert, weißt du, mein kleines Sofa, lag ich zusammengekauert hinter diesem Sofa und hab geharret und alle Leute, die Eltern kamen und haben sich unterhalten, ich hab auch gehört, wie die Leute einfach schamlos über mich gesprochen haben, alle hab ich alles mitbekommen und einmal fand ich so gut, dass eine Mutter von einer anderen Schauspielerin war dann auch so kurz Backstage und wollte ihre Tochter was bringen und sieht mich auf der Bühne liegen und kommt zu mir hin und fragt, Entschuldigung, ist alles in Ordnung? Und dachte, ich würde irgendwie tot einfach auf der Bühne liegen oder hätte keinen Schlag an, verlippt und ich so, nee, ist alles in Ordnung, das gehört zum Stück.
Was natürlich Maximum Unkoll, dass wir alle gesehen haben, dass eine Frau mit dir spricht.
Ja, dass irgendwie so eine Hand, so eine gestikulierende Hand hinter dem Sofa hochkommt und dann einfach niemand mehr überrascht war, als im Stück plötzlich jemand hinter dem Sofa auftaucht. Ja, sehr gut. Aber tatsächlich eine ähnliche geile Situation habe ich mal gespielt, Biedemann und die Brandstifter, und die Idee war, dass der dritte Brandstifter, wieder eine ähnliche Idee, die ganze Zeit im Publikum sitzt, und dann, wenn sein Auftritt gekommen ist, steht er aus dem Publikum auf und geht auf die Bühne und kommt dazu und spielt mit. Und wir haben das halt geprobt in dem Theater, immer wieder wunderbar, alles klar, super, Proben, allerdings wurde diese ganze Geschichte wesentlich interessanter gemacht, als ich erfahren habe, dass wir am Aufführungstag geschminkt werden sollten.
Und zwar nicht nur so klassisch als Theaterschminke, sondern so ganz krass mephistophelisch, so ganz weiss und so schwarze Striche im Auge, so ganz teuflisch aussehen. Und wir dann gedacht haben, ja Moment mal, für die erste Hälfte des Theaterstücks sitzt halt einfach ein alter Mann, der aussieht wie einer von Kiss, die ganze Zeit im Publikum und niemand fragt sich, sag mal, cooles Theater, aber was ist eigentlich mit dem Typen los? Und lauter Kinder und alle saßen drumherum und er so, hallo, guten Abend, guten Abend, und beim Publikum wusste ja niemand, dass er mitspielt. Also er war fantastisch und ich war dann auch da, weil der Aufgang da in der Nähe war und ich kann mich noch so gut erinnern, wie dann so eine Mutter kam mit ihren Kindern und so Plätze gesucht hat und die Kinder so, ah, wir können uns ja da hinsetzen und die Mutter sieht so diesen alten Mann mit Schminke und so, na, lass doch nochmal gucken, ob wir drüben noch was finden. Und ich fand es so lustig, wenn dieser Mann auch der netteste Mensch der Welt war, aber einfach durch dieses Make-up da saß. Einfach grossartig. Einfach einfach fantastisch. Das ist so super. Das hatte ich auch mal bei dem Musical, das ich aufgeführt habe, wo ich dann singen musste. Und dann kam irgendwann, es gab nur ein Klavier und halt die Sänger. Und irgendwann kam halt die Idee auf, den Vorhang zuzumachen für dieses Stück. Und ich stehe halt nur vor dem Vorhang und singe und das Klavier befindet sich hinter dem Vorhang. Es wurde aber nie geprobt, aber die Idee kam halt während der Generalprobe irgendwann auf. Und dann habe ich, während ich gesungen habe, gemerkt, dass dadurch, dass der Vorhang zu ist, man das Klavier nicht mehr hört. Was so Unool ist. Und durch irgendeinen Grund hat dann die Dirigentin bzw. Regisseurin aber das Klavier noch gehört. Und dann ist sie aufgestanden im Publikum und hat dann mich wild versucht, mit den Händen dieses Lied zu begleiten, war aber keine Chance. und ich bin einfach weggelaufen mit dem Gesang. Aber es ist mir erst im Nachhinein aufgefallen, weil ich das, also dass ich so aus dem, out of key und aus dem Takt war, weil man so Adrenalin getränkt gar nicht daran glaubt, überhaupt falsch zu sein. Man denkt, aber gut, ich werde schon irgendwie durchgekommen sein. Und dann irgendwann kam dann die DVD, war dann fertig, die irgendein Elternteil geschnitten hat. Und dann wurde sie mir gegeben, die DVD, mit den Worten, ja gut, du musst sie dir aber gar nicht angucken, du musst sie auch gar nicht kaufen, wir zwingen euch auch gar nicht zu kaufen, und sei nicht zu streng mit dir.
Und ich so, ja gut, ich war schon ganz okay, ich war schon ganz okay, ich meine, gut, Dankeschön trotzdem, ich nehme den Rat gerne an, aber danke für die DVD, und dann dachte ich mir auch, als ich ihn gesehen habe zum ersten Mal, ui, ja gut, upsala. Vielleicht sollte ich doch einen mässig erfolgreichen Podcast machen und das mit dem Singen lassen. Das war grossartig. Ja, sehr gut. Nimm es nicht zu hart, das habe ich bei meinem ersten Sextape auch gehört. There's no business life. Aber es gibt auch nicht schöneres als diese Amateur-Kunstveranstaltung, oder? Auf jeden Fall. schönste, was es gibt. Kann ich noch mal ganz kurz, ich will noch ein neues Segment einführen, den fucking badass Moment der Woche. Ich weiß nicht, ich kann ja gucken, ob er normalerweise von dir kommt oder von mir. Ja. Aber ich hatte einen badass Moment der Woche gestern. Was hast du gemacht? Und zwar sass ich im ICE und schon relativ voll, kleines Mädchen, setzte sich neben mich, denke mir, okay, see where this is going.
Wie alt war sie? Elf oder neun vielleicht, so was ja. Ich lockere also meine Krawatte, ja, machst du die Jackett so ein bisschen auf, so, na, wie heißt es? Auf jeden Fall war die wahnsinnig nervig und hat wahnsinnig viele Fragen gestellt und irgendwann habe ich so geteilt, als würde ich schlafen.
Sind die viele Fragen gestellt? Echt? Wie bist du denn?
Hat mir viele Fragen gestellt, die hat konstant gelabert, einfach nur hat mir von ihrer Schule erzählt und so. Und ich kann ganz gut mit Kindern und habe dann irgendwie sie mehrfach auf meine einstweilige Verfügung hingewiesen. Aber wie großartig ist das denn, dass plötzlich ein Kind die einfach erzählt, aus der Schule erzählt? Wie cool ist das denn? Ja, keine Ahnung, die hat auch schon davor die ganze Zeit gelabert, aber die standen halt dann rum. Und dann hat sie sich hingesetzt und dann irgendwie hat sie einfach gleich weiter gelabert und einfach gedacht, okay, ist auch ein Erwachsener, ist vielleicht mein Vater, vielleicht, also Wahrscheinlichkeit ist relativ hoch und hat einfach weiter gelabert.
Was hast du denn erzählt, dass er schuletzt? Das ist nämlich ja sehr.
Ja, sie hat erzählt, dass sie sich mit manchen Kindern nicht so gut versteht.
Ja, warum denn so, was ist denn da los? Ja, irgendwie die ärgern mich und so und keine Ahnung.
Ich habe dann erzählt, ja, es ist ganz wichtig, dass du immer du selbst bleibst und machen Podcasts und so.
Und dann aber ganz kurz um so Bad West-Moment der Woche zu kommen, hat sie mich gefragt, du, ähm, schätzt mal, wann ich Geburtstag habe. So, ich dachte mir, okay, viel Potenzial für richtig gute Antworten jetzt. Für ein semi-gutes Publikum, also jeder Gag wird vermutlich nicht ankommen, weil das Ironieverständnis bei neunjährigen noch nicht da ist. Und ich habe nachgedacht und habe mir gedacht, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, was kann ich sagen, was ist eine coole Antwort? Heute. Exakt, ich habe gesagt, heute und sie mit grossen Augen, ja, woher wusstest du das? Ja, geil, tatsächlich heute. Ich dachte mir einfach nur so, bam, badass, hoffentlich hat das jemand gehört, ey, fucking in your face, du scheisskind, ey, super gut. Aber weißt du, warum man das nicht schneller fragen kann? Aber warum sollte sie diese Frage stellen, wenn sie nicht? Ja, ich weiß, aber ich finde es schon ganz cool irgendwie. Ja! Vor allem das ist ja ein dankbares Publikum, weil sie checkt es ja nicht, sondern sie denkt, ich hätte gerade wirklich einfach erraten. Oder ich hätte es irgendwie am Geburtstagskuchen erkannt, der irgendwie zwei Stühle weiter... An dem Partyhut, den sie als Auffat. Ja, genau, an dem Allesgute zum Geburtstag, was sie auf ihr Gesicht gemalt hatte, Kinderschminken. Ja, aber das war ein cooler Moment und ich dachte mir, geil.
Ja, Badass-Moment, gefällt mir sehr gut.
Das war der Badass-Moment.
Das Podcast-Ufo-Badass-Moment.
Ganz kurz, das könnt ihr doch mal schreiben.
Folge 1 und die letzte auch gleichzeitig.
Erster und letzter einfach. Und auch mein Aufruf,
es in die Kommentare zu schreiben, wird nicht passieren.
Weißt du eigentlich, was Samstag ist?
Halloween, uuuuh. Halloween ist ja sowas ganz Besonderes.
Also man fragt sich immer, ich frag mich jedes Jahr, gehe ich wieder als Batman oder lasse ich es sein.
Das ist immer so diese Diskrepanz, der ich mich immer bei Halloween befinde.
Und ich weiss nicht genau, ich habe auch nicht so den Freundeskreis, der dieses Fest so wirklich extrovertiert feiert.
Ich weiss nicht, und ich wäre gerne in einem Freundeskreis, wo man das feiert, weil es einfach, ich finde, das ist das beste Fest. Ich bin ein Riesenhorror-Fan, ich bin Gruselfan, ein Gruselfreak, würde ich fast schon sagen. Ich liebe irre Horrorfilme, die mich zum Schauern bringen. Und ich weiß nicht, du bestimmt auch, aber bist du in so einem Freundeskreis, wo das wirklich extrovertiert gefeiert wird? Du kennst mich, ich bin Gänsehaut-Junkie und wenn ich eins liebe, dann ist es Halloween. Aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, wir haben jetzt, Leute, hört mal ganz kurz zu, es ist 2013 und bei Halloween geht es immer noch nur um Geld. Wer verkauft die meisten Plätzchen, wer hat die grösste Breze dabei und das nervt mich so, dass man einfach nicht mal drüber nachdenkt, was heißt dieses Fest überhaupt. Die Leute verstehen ja gar nicht mehr, was ist denn Halloween überhaupt, was ist denn die Botschaft? Für mich ist Halloween, man könnte es für mich auch, dass Jimmy Kimmel hat einen neuen Viral-Hit raus, Fest nennen. Ich glaube, so ist das auch entstanden tatsächlich, bei den Hun damals. Genau, da gab es diesen Hun Kimmel, Jarl Kimmel, wie ich glaube, der der Chef gewesen von dem Dorf und der hat immer diese Pranks gemacht an Halloween, was es halt noch nicht gab, sondern es wurden einfach Kinder verarscht und da ist das langsam entstanden. Und die Kinder haben sich gewehrt, indem sie sich so angezogen haben wie Wölfe zum Beispiel, wie Wehrwölfe, so ist auch die Legende des Wehrwolfs entstanden, die Mädchen haben sich so Fische über die Füsse gestülpt, so ist die Legende des Weihnachtsmanns gestanden. Des Fische überstülpenden Freaks geworden. Und so hat sich das langsam entwickelt und ich finde das einfach toll, dass man da auch nochmal ein bisschen dran denken kann. Aber ganz kurz, es gibt ja, ich sehe es dir in den Augen an, du hältst dich auch zu Halloween nicht an die Regeln, oder? Du hältst dich nicht an die Regeln. Auch zu Halloween ist mein Rulebook im Müll. Haben tatsächlich viele User geschrieben bei der letzten Folge und die haben bestimmt, ihr haltet euch nie an die Regeln, ich habe so viele tolle Regeln aufgestellt, ihr haltet euch nicht dran, ihr seid solche Anarchisten. Wir haben die Macht, euch Regeln zu geben und die ihr euch halten müsst bei eurem Freizeitprojekt. Aber wisst ihr was? Es ist ein Unterschied zwischen die Regeln absichtlich brechen und die Regeln nicht kennen. Und wir kennen die Regeln nicht, weil wir haben einfach kein Konzept von Regeln und deswegen sind wir von der Natur aus schon rebellisch. Wir sind verdammte Rebellen, ne? Mir ist auch aufgefallen, ich bin sehr, ähm, also ich habe mir neulich gedacht, Menschen
wollen ja, je älter sie werden, immer besonderer sein. Sie wollen was Besonderes sein. Außer wenn es um den Körper geht. Da wollen sie nicht irgendwie besonders herausstechen. Hoffentlich nur nicht besonders sein. Ja, man will vom Charakter her, manchmal auch vom Kleidungsstil her irgendwie besonders sein, auffallen. Aber was den Körperbau geht, will man möglichst normal, möglichst average sein. Und das ist mir klar geworden, als ich mir ein Hemd kaufen musste. Ich musste mir ein weisses Hemd kaufen, eigentlich nichts leichter als das, denkt man ja. Und dann bin ich bei einer ganz netten Frau gelandet, weil man muss dann so Fragen beantworten, auf die man nicht vorbereitet ist als normaler Mensch, Kragenweite. Was ist deine Kragenweite? Das ist nicht so wie die Schuhgröße, wo einfach aus der Pistole geschossen kommt, yo, 54 oder so, weiß ich nicht.
Aber bei Kragenweite ist es anders. Und deswegen musste sie mich messen, hat sie erst meinen Hals gemessen, ach, ist ja ganz normal. Aus Versehen wirkt, äusser ist ja sehr klein für ihre Größe. Dann hat sie meine Taille gemessen, ach, ist ganz normal, und dann hat sie meine Arme gemessen. und dann ist sie so, dann ist sie so, sie so das Blut aus dem Gesicht geschossen und sie hat mich angeguckt, sie haben zu lange Arme, sie haben extra lange Arme, das wäre so eine Schockdiagnose irgendwie, als wäre ich gerade im Krankenhaus und sie wollte mir eine Krebsdiagnose mitbringen, sie haben extra lange Arme und ich war irgendwie von ihr mitgenommen, habe auch wohl erschrocken geguckt ein bisschen erschrocken also man hätte gucken müssen eigentlich aber so nachdem um mich beruhigen zu wollen anscheinend habe ich das gesicht gemacht was gerufen hat bitte beruhige mich jetzt ich habe ich weiß nicht wie ich damit umgehen soll ich habe anscheinend so lange arme aber sie sind kein einzigfall und führt mich dann wie in so einer sitcom zu einem regal wo extra lange arme drunter steht aber wirklich so ein regal Regal, ein riesen Regal, wo dann drüberstehen, extra lange Arme. Und sie führt mich dann so hin, ja, sie sind kein Einzelfall. Und dann habe ich jetzt ein Hemd mit extra langen Armen. Ich habe wahrscheinlich zu lange Arme einfach. Gut, ist mir neulich schon aufgefallen, als ich die einfach hinter mir hergezogen habe, so die Hände auf dem Boden geschliffen sind. Du hast auch sehr grosse Hände. Man muss tatsächlich Stefan immer, wenn man mit Stefan telefoniert, darauf hinweisen. Oft nimmt er einfach sein Handy einfach komplett in die Hand und umringt es völlig mit seiner Faust, sodass er weder einen selbst hört, noch er hört den Anrufer und dann, hallo, hallo, hallo, die Anrufe mit Stefan beginnen immer gleich, dass man sagt, Stefan, nimm nochmal kurz die Hand weg, benutze vielleicht zwei Finger, nicht die ganze Hand, sonst wird das nicht. Es passiert auch oft, dass das Telefon in meinem Ohr verschwindet, während ich telefoniere, wo ich den ganzen Tag rumkramen muss, in meinem grossen Ohr, in meinem extra grossen Ohr. Auch extra, finde ich auch ein guter Ausdruck. Das wäre jetzt irgendwie so ein Bonus, den Gott einem gegeben hat. Extra, extra lange Arm. Dein Ohr hat auch eine eigene Vorwahl, oder? Ich hätte gerne Menschen mit extra langen Armen. So, ganz nett eigentlich. Ja, da ist mir aufgefallen, man will eigentlich überall herausstechen, aber nicht, was die eigenen Körpereigenschaften angeht. Ja, das stimmt auch. Ich habe tatsächlich zufälligerweise heute auch ein Hemd gekauft. Und was ich eigentlich will, ist ein Laden, der genau ein Hemd verkauft. Wo du hingehst, ich will ein Hemd, ah hier, Hemd, okay, tschüss. Und nicht, dass es hier extra slim fit, stretched fit, slim, und man hat einfach keine Ahnung, was das heißt. Aber das mit dem Kragen ist mir auch gekommen, dass dann so Bänderauslagen, mit denen man sich die Kragenweite abmessen konnte. Und anscheinend kann man ja an der Kragenweite die gesamte Größe des Hemds rekonstruieren. Also es reicht ja nur, den Kragen zu messen. Was ich auch nicht glaube. Also sehr dicke Menschen. Haben auch aber sehr dicke Kragen. Haben sehr dicke Krägen. Kragen. Sodass man nicht genau weiß, aber man weiß auch nicht, was da drunter kommt, also was unter dem dicken Hals kommt noch. Vielleicht kommt sehr viel Bauch, vielleicht kommt sehr lang, sehr wenig, man weiß ja nicht, was da drunter noch kommt, also ich glaube nicht, dass man das kann, aber anscheinend schon. Also die Frage wirklich, die Kragenweite ist so eine, das ist wie die erste Frage bei Subway, was für ein Brot, das ist ungefähr die eine, auf einer Stufe steht das ungefähr. Er ist ähnlich
einflussreich, da kann man dann
absattend viel falsch machen.
So, hinter Hemdanecdote habe ich
gerade einen Haken gemacht, gedanklich.
Gut.
Wo wären wir?
Gags, Gags, Gags.
Naja, Mensch,
Stefan. Aber ich möchte auch
eigentlich Halloween mal wieder von Tür zu Tür gehen, ohne dass irgendwann ein Anwalt neben mir steht und die Polizei sagt. Es ist Januar, es ist Anfang Januar, was machen Sie hier, Teitzel? Dann kommt die Halloween-Polizei, die sagt, nein, ein Race zu Oktober. Da müssen die das feiern. Süsses, saures oder das Podcast-Ufo, sage ich oft, als Gag. Verstehen die Leute meistens nicht, aber... Haust du Gags manchmal auch nur für dich raus, damit du lachst, aber alle anderen nicht? Doch, ich habe heute auch laut gelacht. Habe ich mal. Lachst du, ist dann egal, lachst du dann für dich nur allein oder versuchst du immer, dass das Gag so Luke Mockridge-mässig alle einholen müssen? Also machst du einfach auch mal einen Gag für dich? Vor allem einen Gag, wo du weißt, der kommt nicht an, weil du ihn schon tausendmal erzählt hast und der kam noch nie an, aber du hast ihn trotzdem noch mal raus. Ich versuche extra laut zu lachen, um möglichst allen anderen im Karstadt zu zeigen, wie wahnsinnig viel Spaß ich gerade habe, mir einen Gürtel auszusuchen. Mir einen Koffer zu kaufen. Damit die Leute einfach denken, oh shit, irgendwas mache ich verdammt falsch. Der hat so viel Spaß mit dem Gürtel, ich habe Gürtel bis jetzt immer komplett falsch benutzt. Und einfach, um die Leute ein bisschen zu verunsichern. Was für eine Gürtelgröße hast du? Sehr gute Frage. Mich überfordert das alles total. Komplett einfach. Ich habe einfach immer, ich kam mir so dumm dabei vor, diesen Gürtel von der Stange zu nehmen und einfach umzulegen und einfach so anzubrühren und sagen, okay, passt, nehme ich. Das war mir so unangenehm, weil das so albern aussieht, obwohl das eigentlich das einzige ist, was man mit einem kleinen Stück macht. Jeder weiß, was man mit diesem Gürtel machen wird. Das ist ja kein Geheimnis. Alle wissen ja, was man mit dem Gürtel macht. Ich hätte gerne so ein Tableau, wo man einmal am Anfang einträgt, alle Werte, die man hat, die man einmal misst. Und dann muss man einmal irgendwie durch so einen Scanner gehen, einmal im Jahr. Durch eine Blutprobe, ja. Und dann aktualisiert es diese Daten und du kannst einfach dann beim Gürtelkauf, welche Gürtelgröße haben sie denn? A, hier, V, P. Evanescence, ja, je nachdem, wie die diese komischen nennen, Smiley, trauriger Smiley. Ich habe Nasensmiley-Größe. Warum jetzt Nase? Ist mir gerade eingefallen. Kannst du da nochmal näher drauf eingehen, bitte? Ich habe neulich darüber nachgedgedacht, irgendwie bei diesen Asci-Zeichen, so diese ganzen, dieses Asci-Alphabet, wo es was ja mit A anfängt und gemeinhin mit Z und irgendwann der Null und Sonderzeichen aufhören, sind jetzt ja auch die Smileys reingerutscht. Also die haben jetzt wirklich eine grössere Tragweite, also sie sind jetzt anscheinend wirklich im Alphabet angelangt. Und da frage ich mich auch, wann irgendwann auch mal hier U-Bahn-Schilder oder so Autobahn-Schilder einfach mit Smileys versehen werden. Oder Namen, wann das erste Kind auf die Welt kommt. Ausfahrt, Oberhausen und dann so ein Trauer-Smiley oder so. So eine Bewertung auch gleich. Oder die ersten Namen. Wann wird das erste Kind geboren, das diesen Zähneknirschensmiley heißt oder dann diesen Schulterzugsmiley oder sowas. Worry. Wann wird das geschehen? Worry. Oder dieses Äffchen, das sich den Mund zuhält. Wie würdest du dein Kind nennen, wenn du jetzt ein Kind bekämpfst, morgen? Baffolev. Baffolev. Baffolev. Magst du darauf eingehen, oder? Nö, ich halte mich sehr sehr. Der Künstler lehnt sich zurück und sagt, interpretiert ihr mal, macht ihr mal.
Finde ich auch nicht schlecht, wenn man sein Kind als Kunstwerk ansieht und sich deswegen aus allem ausreden kann, wie es sich verhält und einfach sich zurücklehnt die ganze Zeit und sagt, ja, man gucken, wie die Umwelt auf dieses Kunstwerk reagiert. Apropos Kunstwerk, es gibt ja eine neue Kraft in unserem Leben, bis jetzt waren wir nur zu zwei.
Warte mal, aber ganz kurz, ich höre dich schon wieder nicht. Kannst du mal wieder dein VPN ausmachen oder was du da auch immer für eine Scheiße gerade wieder am Start hast? Alter, das ist Hass, Thema Hass. Jetzt hat er schon wieder irgendwie, zockt Dota während er mit mir spricht oder so, ein Crap. Und ich weiß einfach nicht, ich höre dich nicht mehr. Ich höre dich, bei mir ist alles gut. Ich weiß nicht, was du hast. Wie wollen wir weitermachen? Wollen wir kurz ein Hörspiel einschieben, der Trailercheck der Woche vielleicht? Ich dachte, dass wir uns immer einen Trailer anschauen, aber keinen echten Trailer. Wir können auch bei Bond reden. Nee. So was auch uncool ist, dass wir das nicht. Wir können auch bei Star Wars reden, über den Star Wars Trailer, der rausgekommen ist. Und den live gucken. Genau, können wir analysieren. Was wir davon halten, dass jetzt Poe und Gengis Khan und viele Beisel jetzt tatsächlich den Todesstern übernehmen.
Und Shir Khan.
Und Shir Khan, genau. Und Snake.
Und wir sind wieder drauf, in drei, zwei und go! Ahahahahaha! Ahahahahaha! Ahahahahaha!
Ahahahahaha!
Oh Mann, Entschuldigung, ich will jetzt ganz kurz.
Es ist ja auch sehr gut, wie Menschen wieder aus so einer Lachernummer herauskommen.
Oft kommt dann nur ganz viel Nachhall so. Und dann wird es interessant, wann der Blick wiederkommt von man lacht noch mit dem Gesicht, aber man nicht mehr laut, zu ernst, dass wieder das Gesicht ernst wird, quasi unoffiziell gesellschaftlich akzeptiert, dass Lachen überwunden hat. Spannend. Das haben ja viele Leute tatsächlich geschrieben, dass sie unzufrieden sind, dass wir mit unseren Figuren so inkonsequent sind. Manchmal ist Stefan der Lustige, manchmal ist Carsten der lustige, dann ist wieder Schirkan der lustige. Lass mal Florentin der lustige sein, warum ist Florentin der lustige? Aber Leute da draußen, wir sind echte Menschen, wir sind keine Figuren, wir sind wirklich so, okay? Ey, ich weiss, das ist manchmal ein bisschen crazy, das zu akzeptieren, so, ey, wir laufen da wirklich so einfach draußen rum in dieser crazy Welt, aber wir sind halt einfach so, okay? Und wir wollen uns dafür auch nicht entschuldigen. Wir sind wie so Knetfiguren, wir sind wie Play-Doh. Man muss uns vorsichtig sein, wie man uns anfasst, weil wir sind da zu eurem Vergnügen. Aber ihr könnt sie formen
und wenn ihr zu doll draufhaut
und die Farben vermischt
und auf den Boden legt,
dann ist es einfach irgendwann
dreckig und scheiß und schäbig und die Lege legt es weg.
Also liegt es auch ein bisschen an euch,
wie ihr da mit diesem Vergnügungsobjekt umgeht.
Wie hast du die Zeitumstellung erfahren?
War das für dich ein krasser Druck?
Ich bin so müde.
Ich bin... umgeht. Wie hast du die Zeitumstellung erfahren? Also war das für dich irgendwie ein krasser Druck?
Ich bin so müde. Ich fasse
es nicht. Und es war auch noch Vollmond
in der Nacht.
Es war auch noch Vollmond.
Und denke ich mir auch, Leute,
das kann...
Können wir mal ganz kurz Pro und Contra von Mond
einfach mal zusammenfassen. Contra, man kann nicht schlafen. Contra ist es zu hell in der Nacht. Haben wir irgendwo ein Pro? Okay, Gezeiten. Okay, von mir aus. Nein, Contra, Gezeiten. Leute sterben, Leute sterben, weil die denken, oh, hier ist Land, hier kann ich langgehen. Wow, cool, und da hätten wir auch noch eine Führung gemacht, eine Wanderung, Wattwanderung, oh nein, was ist das, das Blaue bewegt sich, tot, Menschen sterben, Contra, grosses Contra. Sein letzter Satz, das Blaue bewegt sich, da wird sich auch, okay, Contra, haben wir irgendeinen Plus, okay, es gibt ganz nette Lieder über den Mond, die wir jetzt nicht verluten, Maroon 5, es gibt einen guten Film, Moon, aber ansonsten haben wir eigentlich nicht viel auf der Haare verbucht.
Doch, die Erde wird im Gleichgewicht gehalten. Ich glaube, dadurch, dass der Mond sich andauernd drum dreht, wird die Erde stabilisiert. Und angenommen, ich glaube, dass das ja einigermaßen viele Kometen abhält, die auf die Erde zurasen. Ich glaube, wir könnten unter dem Mond nicht leben.
Ich habe nämlich übrigens vom Mond geträumt, als neulich wirklich, da war dieser Supermond, Supermond-Blutmond war auch irgendwie, es war ganz viele Monde waren irgendwie gleichzeitig da. Ein roter Mond ist aufgegangen. Ein roter Mond ist aufgegangen, heute Nacht ist Blut vergossen worden, man kennt die Sätze, und dann habe ich in der Nacht geträumt, dass ich in meiner Heimat war und plötzlich alle aufgeregt sind und irgendwas war los und dann bin ich rausgegangen und der Mond, man hat den Mond wegrasen sehen von der Erde und dann ist die Welt untergegangen tatsächlich. Also die Welt ist untergegangen, weil der Mond weggerast ist. Ist das für dich prophetisch? Ich habe massive Probleme, die sich in meinen Träumen widerspiegeln. Massive Probleme, ja, aber die Natur der Probleme ist ja nicht so ganz eindeutig. Also der Mond ist für mich ein... Fühlst du dich manchmal wie der Mond? Also du fliegst um jemanden rum, der grösser ist als du und von dem du nicht loskommst? Ja, ich fühle mich... Du bist so ein bisschen meine Erde. Also du... Ich schwebe die ganze Zeit um dich herum und halte dich im Gleichgewicht. Ich glaube, unheimlich würde es so komplett zerbersten, aber wir brauchen uns gegenseitig und noch bin ich durch dich angewiesen, ich bin auf dich angewiesen, dass du mich in deiner Bahn hältst und allein im Universum wäre ich noch niemals ein Planet. Ich wäre wie Pluto, so irgendwie zwischen Planet und Mond irgendwo angesehen, aber irgendwann werde ich grösser als du sein oder Oder auch nicht draufkrachen. Wir werden beide sterben. Wir kreisen ja beide um noch einen grösseren, um eine Sonne. Um Stefan Raab. Wir kreisen um Stefan Raab. Sozusagen. Das Podcast-Ufo ist ja so ein bisschen die Untertitel des Lebens eigentlich, oder? Ah, jetzt kommt ja so eine selbstreferenzielle Scheiße. Bitte? Bitte? Du hast schon richtig gehört, mein Lieber. Du, hey, wenn du dich mit mir anlegen willst. Ich hab leider nicht verstanden, was du gesagt hast. Wir können auch kurz rausgehen. Ja, komm, wir gehen kurz raus. Hey! Hey, Stefan! Ja, was soll die Scheiße da drin? Hey, was soll das denn? Ich hau mich auch nicht auf den Pressen. Da braucht man sich aber verlassen. Hier im Podcast immer die grosse Klappe haben und dann nichts dahinter, oder was? Das nächste Mal hau ich dir in die Fresse, darauf kannst du dich nicht verlassen, mit einer Scheisskarren Holland. Mit deinen Stummelarm, du. Da kannst du keinem mehr was in die Fresse hauen. Ja, komm her, du! Hey, komm nur her, Mann! Ach, was ist los? Hey, was macht ihr da? Was ist los?
Was? Auseinander, auseinander.
Der gruselige alte Mann vom Eisstranz kommt.
Was macht ihr da?
Wollt ihr dich lieber ein Eis kaufen, anstatt euch zu streiten?
Kommst du noch Zeit, ich höre dir die Fresse.
Ich höre dir die Fresse, wenn du noch Zeit, wenn du hierher kommst.
Warum denn?
Warum? Ich kann dir ein Eis ver...
Stefan, das wäre jetzt echt nicht nötig gewesen.
Fuck, Mann. Er ist tot. Er ist dabei tot. Fuck, was machen wir jetzt? Er ist tot. Und seitdem war Stefan Tietze ein anderer Mensch. Seitdem man sagt, wenn man jemanden umbringt, teilt sich seine Seele in Hockrux auf. Und seitdem hat Stefan Tietze seine Seele zum ersten Mal in zwei Hockruxel aufgeteilt. Der erste war der Eisverkäufer und der zweite ein Eisstiel, den er irgendwo in einer Magnumfabrik versteckt hat. Und irgendwann mal wird ein Magnumkonsument auf diesen Stiel aufmerksam werden und die tote Seele Stefan Thiezes anlecken. Stefan Thieze wird dann ein wohliges Gefühl durchfahren. So wurde er noch nicht so gut. Aber auch ein bisschen beschämt. Er wird auch kurz rot anlaufen. Wohlig. Naja, ich wollte mal kurz auf was eingehen. Ja, lass mal. Ich wollte mal kurz auf was eingehen. Ich habe schon mal als Tweet rausgehauen, finde es aber so interessant, dass ich gerne mal mit dir darüber sprechen würde, weil ich finde, du bist so ein Experte, ich rede mit dir gerne über dieses Thema. Das Thema ist Religion. Und zwar habe ich gelesen, dass in der Bibel neunmal das Wort Einhorn vorkommt. Neunmal das Wort Einhorn. Finde ich schon wahnsinnig lustig. Und alles auf der ersten Seite. Das ist eine knalle Einleitung. Das ist wie bei Monty Python, diese Szene mit dem Alien, bei das Leben des Brian, wo niemand genau weiss, wo er das UFO jetzt genau. Und das ist so ein bisschen ein Kapitel in der Bibel, wo niemand genau weiss, warum reden die jetzt da von Einhörnern und mehr Jungfrauen. Ja, vor allem, ich habe gehört, eine Fantheorie zur Bibel ist ja, dass das erste Testament, also das alte Testament, komplett nur von Jesus geträumt wurde. Dass es gar nicht wirklich passiert ist, sondern es nur eine Traumsequenz ist. Ich habe gehört, dass das neue Testament Fanfiction ist vom alten Testament. Und dass Jesus es selbst geschrieben hat? Ne, dass Fans das geschrieben haben ein bisschen ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein und ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein bisschen mehr als ein und gesagt, ey, neunmal kommt das Wort Einhorn in der Bibel vor, Leute, hey! Und dann, wie ich halt so bin, bin ich in meiner Bekanntschaft rumgelaufen und habe gesagt, ey, neunmal kommt das Wort Einhorn in der Bibel vor, Leute, hey! Und dann hat mir irgendwer gesagt, ja, ja, das sind Übersetzungsfehler nur, das ist nur ein Übersetzungsfehler. Und dann dachte ich mir, Moment mal kurz. Der enttäuschendste Übersetzungsfehler aller Zeiten. Ja, ich dachte mir dann, als ich damals in Latein habe ich oft Texte übersetzt. So, und dann habe ich, wenn ich ein Wort neunmal falsch übersetzt habe, habe ich entweder keine Ahnung gehabt, wovon ich da gerade rede überhaupt, oder ich hatte einfach keine Lust, so einfach keine Lust auf diesen Text. Und ich denke mir, also macht das nicht noch viel schlimmer, wenn wir offensichtlich etwas lesen und anbeten in unserer Gesellschaft, dass immer noch Leute, Bundeskanzler und so, darauf schwören und Eids ablegen, wo offensichtlich jemand entweder absolut keine Ahnung hat, was er da gerade übersetzt, oder aber absolut keinen Bock. Was ist da los, was ist schlimmer, Übersetzungsfehler oder wirklich das Wort Einhorn im Endeffekt drin zu haben? Man fragt sich, was sind dann alles andere noch Übersetzungsfehler, was ist da eigentlich tatsächlich vorgefallen, und vor allem, wo kommen die ganzen Übersetzungsfehler rein, war da irgendein Scheisspraktikant, der das mal irgendwie nebenbei so übersetzt hat, wie gesagt, Autokorrektur, ja, wahrscheinlich, sowas in der Richtung, oder einfach faule, faule Jünger, die einfach gesagt haben, ich spreche kein Hebräisch, ich denke mir einfach was selber aus, weil das ist sowieso so abgefragt. Die Deadline, Leute, Petros, morgen muss der Text fertig sein, hau jetzt was da raus, mal verdammt nochmal, morgen ist die Deadline und er haut in die Tasten und hat nicht genau gewusst, Google war da damals auch schwierig, glaube ich, war sehr langsam noch damals, hat sehr lange gebraucht, um was zu übersetzen. Zwei Ergebnisse und dafür gebraucht 2600 Jahre, das war immer gedauert. Da ist Google auch wahnsinnig angeblich,
dass sie immer sagen müssen,
ich habe eine unfassbar geringe
Anzahl von Sekunden gebraucht,
die du dir niemals vorstellen kannst, weil sie so gering ist.
0, Mikrosekunden
habe ich gebraucht, um die Milliarden Ergebnisse
zu empfangen. Das hat dein langsames, menschliches
Auge gar nicht verarbeiten können,
wie schnell es ging. Oh, sorry,
aber das lag jetzt nicht an mir.
Selbst dein Router war viel zu langsam dafür, selbst dein Router, der nur dafür gemacht ist, Schnelligkeit zu verbreiten, hat es nicht geschafft, das hinzukriegen. Moment, wir haben jetzt schneller gesucht, als Elektronen sich überhaupt bewegen können im Vakuum, ach, das ist ja verrückt, wie das jetzt passieren konnte, naja. Entschuldigung. Moment mal, wir haben die Antwort gefunden, bevor du sie eingegeben hast, ups, wie konnte das denn passieren? Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, entschuldigung, entschuldig, entschuldig, naja, komm das nächste Mal einfach vielleicht ein bisschen früher vorbei, naja, ich bin ja immer noch hier, ich bin immer da, wenn du mich brauchst. Mach's gut, ciao, verabschiedet sich, verabschiedet sich einfach, Google. Ich glaube, ich glaube, Google redet auch immer noch lange weiter, nachdem man die Seite schon verlassen hat. Man ist schon weg, aber Google redet noch immer weiter so, ja, ich habe das noch gefunden und hier ist noch ein Artikel und so, aber du bist schon lange weg. Wie geht es dir eigentlich, wenn du bei Google was eingibst und dann kommt unten dieses, ja, die restlichen Ergebnisse verstecken wir aus datenschutzrechtlichen und jugendschutzrechtlichen Gründen, wollen wir dir jetzt nicht anzeigen, wenn da dieser kursive Text kommt. Wie fühlst du dich da an? Wie ein Creep, wie jemand, der es richtig gemacht hat, der offensichtlich mal die richtigen Fragen gestellt hat? Das Problem ist, es kommt eigentlich fast nur dann vor, wenn ich nach meinem eigenen Namen google und dann fragt man sich schon so ein bisschen, hm, okay, was sind das für Links und da ist dann oft meine eigene Fanfiction, die ich geschrieben habe zu Winnie-Poo und so was in der Richtung. Ja, ja, sowas. Warum hat man eigentlich nicht in der Schule früher seine Spicker nur auf die Rückseite von Kinderpornos geschrieben? Weil das nimmt einen der Lehrer garantiert nicht ab. Warum hat man als Kind vor allem nicht Kinderpornos aufgenommen und kann die dann später für teuer Geld verkaufen? Jetzt kann ich es nicht mehr. Ein Verdreckt verkaufen. Jetzt kann ich es nicht mehr. Das stimmt, das ist eigentlich ein klassischer Angebot-Nachfrage-Ding. Es ist ein klassischer Angebot-Nachfrage-Fehler. Ja. Also, ein Tipp an die Kids da draußen. Falls ihr Bock habt, ordentlich Geld zu verdienen, dann... Ich wollte jetzt aus strafrechtlichen Gründen den Satz nicht selber beenden, sondern es nicht machen lassen. Weil, wenn jeder nur die Hälfte eines Verbrechens begeht, ich sage, Kinder ihr sollt und du sagst Kinderpornos machen, dann ist niemand von uns strafbar. Ich glaube nicht die Hälfte. Doch klar, natürlich funktioniert das. Ich glaube, es ist der, der die Hälfte zu Ende bringt. Wenn ich jetzt jemanden halb umbringe und du bringst ihn dann letztendlich um, diesen Menschen, ich glaube nicht, dass ich dann derjenige bin, der belangt wird.
Aber das kann man ja anders schneiden.
Du kannst es ja noch anders schneiden.
Und dann weiss man ja gar nicht, ob das zusammengehört.
Angenommen, du nimmst jetzt irgendwie eine Aufzeichnung von Evanescence oder so
und schneidest da so einzelne Silben raus,
so dass es dann am Ende klingt irgendwie wie, keine Ahnung, Hitler lebt,
dann ist ja auch nicht Evanescence strafbar. Ich glaube auch niemand ist strafbar, wenn Hitler lebt. Aber ich glaube, Evanescence ist strafbar, egal was sie sagen. Ich glaube, da ist es eine Extraklausel. Evanescence. Wie bitte? Evanescence. Evanescence. Evanescence. Evanescence. Evanescence, Norma, Evanescence, Titzel, Freddy Krüger, Halloween. Du machst bestimmt auch deine Wohnung, baust du so grossartig hin auf, so so ein Themenfeld und dann denkst du die Geschichte aus und Kinder kommen rein und werden überrascht von immer neuen, von einer Kettenreaktion aus lustigen Skeletten und Federmäusen, die sich in eine Wohnung fliegen. Leider sind es echte wahrscheinlich. Ja, ich sollte mal für Kinder tatsächlich eine Halloween-Party organisieren, was so ungefähr das Lameste ist, was ich jemals in meinem Leben gemacht habe, weil nichts ist schlimmer als für Kinder eine Party zu organisieren, weil du weißt genau, okay, die hängen die ganze Zeit an ihrem Smartphone, Kinder sind heute nicht mehr so wie früher.
Und wenn heute Erwachsene eine Party organisieren wollen, dann denken sie nicht, dass sie eigentlich die ganze Zeit auf Twitter nebenbei sind. Und meine Aufgabe war es, gruseliges Essen zu machen. Und dann natürlich der Klassiker, so Fingerwienerwürste, das heißt, du holst so eine Wienerwurst und schiebst dann vorne so eine Mandelscheibe rein, so dass es aussieht wie ein Fingernagel. Jetzt sollten die Kinder das aber selber machen, habe ich denen gesagt, ja, schiebt dann so, damit es so aussieht wie ein Finger. Was sie letztendlich gemacht haben, sie haben eine ganze Mandel genommen und einfach in die Wurst vorne mittig einfach das reingesteckt. Es sah null aus wie ein Finger und dann lagen auf dem Tisch einfach bergeweise wieder Würste mit einer Mandel drin, die einfach gegessen wurden und niemand hat sich gefragt, was ist denn da los? Aber es wurde einfach hingenommen, es ist dann auch egal. Man fragt dann auch nicht nach. Entschuldigung, sehr nette Wurst, aber komische Kombinationen, Mandel und Wurst. Ich finde vor allem, dass Essen sowas ist, was man dann nicht unbedingt noch anrühren muss. Also gerne bei Tempa, da wird ja dann immer das Essen dann so dekoriert. Aber warum? Ich meine, das ist doch so sinnlos. Aber man kann es ja auch faul machen. Du kannst ja einfach Spaghetti machen und dann sagen, das ist Gehirnmasse oder Würmer oder was auch. Hier, diese rote Kirschschorle ist Blut. Das ist jetzt Blut. Trinkt es. Der Gastgeber trinkt es jetzt, trinkt es jetzt, das Blut. Sympathischer Gastgeber. Das ist Blut. Nee, trinkt es mal jetzt. Das geht schon. Hast du schon mal Blut getrunken, Blut probiert? Mein eigenes, literweise. Aber es geht ja, weil das ist ja wie so ein Kreislauf, ne? Ja. Weil es ist ja dein Blut, du kannst ja so viel, genauso wie du Spucke trinken kannst, so viel du willst. Macht Spucke eigentlich das Gegenteil von durstig? Fehlt das Vokabular. Nein. Warum gibt es dafür kein Wort? Ja. Trinken satt. Ich bin jetzt das Gegenteil von durstig. Sagt man auch einfach nie. Man kommt nie in die Situation, es zu sagen. Hey, willst du noch ein Glas Wasser? Nee, ich bin schon... Aber es gibt ja ein gutes Worte dafür gefunden. Ich bin jetzt sowas von nicht mehr durstig. Ich bin wahnsinnig... Ich bin so voll. Ich kann nicht mehr trinken. Ja, aber du kannst auch nicht zu viel trinken. Ich habe mal gehört, wenn man zu viel Wasser trinkt, bringt um einfach auch. Ja, bei so einem Wettbewerb, wo eine V verlost wurde, wer am meisten Wasser trinken kann, von so einem Radiosender hat einen Wettbewerb gemacht, wer kann am meisten Wasser trinken und gewinnt eine V und irgendeine Frau aus Amerika hat einfach 19 Liter getrunken und ist halt einfach gestorben. Aber mit einer V. Und heute mit einer V. So auf dem Sarg kommt noch der Radiomoderator, hallo Leute, na wie geht's, you guys, und legt nochmal so eine V oben auf den Sarg einfach drauf. Muss halt schon sein. Wie großartig, und der Vater hält dann so die V hoch, sie ist tot, aber sie starb für einen guten Zweck. Das nimmt uns niemand mehr! Schnitt, sie zocken wie Wii Sports Tennis oder so. Ja genau, und der Sarg wird runtergefahren und die Super Mario Untergrundmusik wird eingespielt. Weinen. Ich finde es so grossartig, dass man Wee hat man auch nie, wenn man weinend Wee-Sports machen soll. So weinend von einem Wee-Spiel. So ein Wee-Horrorspiel. Man hat total Angst, muss aber trotzdem noch dumm rumfummeln eigentlich. Ja, genau. Sehr gut. Ja, lieber Florentin, ich bedanke mich bei dir dafür, dass du dich so schick gemacht hast heute für diese Aufseichtung. Ich sehe dich mal wieder. Dankeschön. Und du hast dich wirklich, du hast ein Hemd, eine Krawatte, du hast dir so ein, was wie sieht man das, ein Sweater drübergezogen, aber so ein feinen, ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt, beginne die Worte aus. Ein Cardigan. Ja, sowas in der Richtung kann sein, glaube ich. Ja, als Probelauf von meinem Halloween-Kostüm. Du gehst wirklich als Harry Potter, ne? Tatsächlich, oder als Random-Typ von Hufflepuff. Ich gehe als Random-Hufflepuff-Student, ja, das ist meine Idee. Ciao! Auch nicht Original-Dialog, den du morgen auf einer Party führen führst. Ich habe heute übrigens, ich musste beruflich eine Redewendung googeln. Und zwar wollte ich die Herkunft der... Wow, Alter, okay, also viel Spaß mit dieser Folge, bis zum nächsten Mal. Und zwar wollte ich die Redewendung Wir Elefanten im Porzellanladen googeln, zumindest die Herkunft. Und du bist auf einen Zeitungsartikel aus dem 18. Jahrhundert in Budapest gestossen, wo es tatsächlich einen Vorfall gab, dass ein Elefant sehr viel Schaden, eine Millionenhöhe an Schaden angerichtet hat. Und alle, die sich gedacht haben, hey, das könnte doch ein gutes Sprichwort sein. Und ich habe keine Erklärung. Weil mit Sprichwörtern ist es ja tatsächlich immer so, man überlegt sich, wie wurde dieses Sprichwort beim ersten Mal. Jesus, Alter! Zum Beispiel Shakespeare hat ja auch eine ganze Menge Sprichwörter. Ja, okay. Einfach Mann, oh die abgestaubt, man. Und ich habe keine Herkunft gefunden, sondern nur folgenden Absatz, der so ein bisschen beschreibt, wie Comedy Deutschland tickt. Nämlich gar nicht. Folgenden Absatz habe ich gefunden. Elefanten sind wegen ihrer grossen Statur nicht sehr wendig. Porzellan hingegen ist sehr empfindlich, da es leicht bricht. Einen Elefanten in einen Porzellanladen zu stecken, wäre sehr fahrlässig, da das bedeuten würde, dass das Porzellan schnell zerstört wäre. Bitte unterlassen Sie es, einen Elefanten in einen Porzellanladen zu stecken.
Das ist eine falsche Idee. Hören Sie auf damit, nach solchen Dingen zu googeln. Das ist keine gute Idee, was auch immer Sie gerade vorhaben. Ist das gut, ey, das ist ja die beste Rubrik aller Zeiten, Sprichwerte zu erklären. Das ist ja fantastisch. Ja, aber vor allem, weil ein Glashaus ist ja sehr zerbrechlich. Wenn man einen Stein dagegen wirft, dann bricht das Haus zusammen. Dann läuft man Gefahr, dass der Stein, wenn man ihn wirkt... Nicht exakt das, wonach ich gesucht habe. Ich habe nach der Herkunft... Das habe ich mir auch schon fast gedacht. Ich weiß, warum das so ist, wie es ist, aber ich dachte, das kommt irgendwo her. Die Tatsache, dass dieses Sprichwort existiert, heißt, dass Leute es verstehen. Die reine Existenz bedeutet, man muss es nicht erklären.
Und die Tatsache... Aber auch diese Sorgfalt, Elefanten sind... Ich nehme vor die Person... Aber auch genau diese Sorgfalt, dass wir erklären, Elefanten sind wegen ihrer grossen Statur nicht sehr wendig. Porzellan hingegen ist sehr empfindlich, da es leicht bricht, diese Sorgfalt, diese Detailtreue da drin. Empfindlich, da es leicht bricht, so ach so, jetzt. Aber ich stelle mir diesen einen Typen vor, der in der Arbeit von mir gesagt bekommt, du bist eine Elefane Porzellanland und sich denkt, was? Und das googelt und dann, ach so, wegen empfindlich, jetzt verstehe ich das Porzellan, ja klar. So gut, herrlich. Da muss ich sehr lachen, vor allem, naja, spricht für sich selbst. Dankeschön für diese Folge, Florentin Will. Ich denke mir, das war bei der Folge, wo ihr sagen werdet, ja, eine normale Folge, wie wir sie kennen und nicht so etwas Experimentelles, wo uns im Nachhinein auch selber aufgefallen ist, dass diese ganzen Geräuschexperimente nicht so ganz gut funktioniert haben, weil die Richtmikrofone nicht so gut waren müssen. Aber das weiss man halt nur im Nachhinein. Das ist halt tatsächlich einer dieser Beispiele, wo man einfach ein Risiko
eingehen muss und entweder klappt es oder nicht. Man kann es nicht, während man es macht, wissen, ob es gut ist oder nicht.
In diesem Sinne, vielen Dank, Florentin Will. Vielen Dank, der Van Theibel. Bis zum nächsten Mal, wenn es wieder heisst, das Podcast-UFO hebt ab,
bitte ohne euch. Wir heben auch jeden Fall ab, bis dann, ciao.